truth at the end of probably every year
when you look back it seems filled with
tumultuously eland ever before this year
is no exception
so tasked with choosing choosing the
pledged person of 2018 it was as big a
challenge as Greg getting through a show
without calling for more taxes or Carol
not mentioning the will of the people
twice but I got there and it's no
preening pompous politician who scoops
the award nor any self-serving
superannuated celebrity rather it is
America's no make that the world's
favorite shopkeeper I speak of our poo
Nahasapeemapetilon faced with the
possibility of being written out of the
show due to fears of racial stereotyping
the king of the kwik-e-mart needs all
the help he can get
our poo is the perfect case study of
what immigrants offer he's hardworking
he never takes a day off he loves his
wife and eight children
he's fiercely proud of the US and he's a
devout Hindu so for all the our poos out
there I salute you for 29 seasons in
America it's it's well it's the
longest-running scripted two primetime
show in America and people start
complaining about it now yes you said in
the Internet this guy devout Hindu
devoted dad he's he works all the hours
God said he's got a cookies a cool guy
he's got a flash car you know lucky and
and they're saying he's the stereotype
the hell sure with stereotypes that sure
was built around stereo and that's
that's the fun of it's fiction and also
but you know Homer being how am I being
the biggest stereotype you know white
overweight denkinger so you know it's
it's supposed to be fun and I just it
really upsets me and then when people
stop putting political correctness onto
something that is not meant to offend
anyone do I make you laugh I think the
breath I think the swear jar should have
had political correctness on it not the
beaver because that is the thing Carol
part
do you have a problem with our Putin s
real suddenly you guys all
pro-immigration Ural my last names are
clue there you go so interesting that I
don't usually feel we're having debates
about immigration that you're all
singing the praises of and I 100% agree
the thousands of incredibly hard-working
aspirational this country well I feel
like we often sit here and talk about
immigration like it's some kind of
existential crisis controlled
integration our country and is there
interesting that then when in the
context of somebody wanting to edit out
a story you think it's politically
correct suddenly it's the immigrant is
the champion and how dare someone if you
looked on social media at the time the
story broke you'd find that they were I
mean I was looking at my there were many
many Indian people who were not offended
by this who said it was funny they got
the joke of the whole show the fact that
the whole show is about stereotypes they
got it and they're not offended by it so
why should you be it's not about me it's
about people sorry just let me finish my
point right because if this was a dress
made but no it's about people of Indian
heritage who know that they're not
represented in the media in anything
like affair when they are fictional
character be the person of the year
seems to me a bit strange my perfect
scene straight you since we first met
your choice now my person of the year I
feel like this long hard is Gareth
Southgate it was the England manager and
I support him not only forgetting
England to the semi-finals of the World
Cup but also but mainly because he
brought intelligence honesty to to a
role that we haven't always seen and
that football is desperately in need of
people like that and I thought South
Gate was an incredibly impressive there
was a very good quote tonight I have to
put my glasses on but it's quite
difficult yes are you gonna get both of
those and the head
this was from The Guardian columnist
John Cray so I thought summed up about
Southgate he said it's not just the team
that Southgate is inspired
it is England as a whole at a time when
the cabinet is fighting like that's in
the sack
and Trust in the political class to act
in the best interest of the country
rather than their own party is at an
all-time low Southgate has shown what it
is to have integrity to stand up and be
counted
he is demonstrated that you could act
with humanity and decency towards others
all sanity of the year doesn't agree
let's just show you one great integrated
it let me just show you one clip of
Southgate when he is comforting the
Colombian players after we knock them
out of things we come I mean who he's a
gracious man the personality which is
worth no but it's a good nomination
aspect in the New Year's Honours coming
up yeah he will get something for
services to waste folks my nomination is
a 15 year old girl called Greta Finn bug
and let's have a clip from her and then
I might say something afterwards you
only speak of a green eternal economic
growth because you are too scared of
being unpopular you only talk about
moving forward with the same bad ideas
that got us into this mess even when the
only sensible thing to do is pull the
emergency brake you are not mature
enough to tell it like it is even that
burden you leave to us children you say
you love your children above all else
and yet you're stealing their future in
front of their very eyes wow I thought
that was unbelievably powerful and
obviously she was speaking at the
two-week home exchange conference and I
just might want say one thing because I
don't on this jar to go empty which is
that she said that the failure of the
government class to do anything about
climate change
we're stealing their children's future
Church as much it's what I feel about if
we do not stop brexit which is going to
steal my grandchildren and
grandchildren's children unless they
stop breakfast or do something to make
sure that if we do have wrecks it as the
people the will of the people determined
it should be in a way that doesn't stop
our children living you have working and
loving on 27 didn't have your country
looking after your own countries for the
last 40 years nomination I agree with
Rachel that I think too much we are
leaving it the burden for the young
people to rescue the mess that old
generations have put us in but there is
one young person that I found inspiring
that year and she is not in my usual
category of places to find inspiration
she's a royal my person dear is Megan
Michael because I think she did more to
open up a debate about race and identity
in Britain than anyone else maybe in my
lifetime and for the first time across
news networks and mainstream TV and
radio and in magazines and newspapers
everybody was asking about what it means
to be British what it means to be mixed
heritage or have African ancestry and be
in one of the most prominent parts of
the British establishment and for me as
a mixed-race girl growing up in Britain
feeling that I couldn't be British
because Britishness was somehow a white
identity that was a very powerful moment
so while I still have my issues with the
royal family and intergenerational
privilege in the monarchy I think she
has been a very inspiring character and
I can see the way that the press were
really turning on her and I think that
she's got a suggestion she's deserted
feminism last week the other day was
that fair Amy I don't think it's fair
she's never been a radical you know she
is somebody who is a self-made women who
has been vocal about her own causes and
I think that many women relate to that
and I think she will continue I hope she
will continue to do that and not be
silenced by a royal family that has not
proved itself very adept at handling
strong-willed independent women in the
past so I think she's going to continue
to challenge that I know I think that
will try thing is is the royal family
the royal family you never take on the
royal family you end up out in the cold
football manager we've got a useful
campaign we've got a cartoon character
we've got a royal and Carol finally so
I'm gonna bring the turn right down but
I actually think and I'm not saying yes
mine is Donald Trump now listen listen
the man is a bore
possibly a misogynist he's got a potty
mouth and you know his his image is not
good
however if I was one of the Americans
who voted for him I would be pretty
happy with the way the country's doing
there was a YouGov poll in the last week
I said that said 37 percent the country
think the country is going in the right
direction that is the highest of speed
for five years the economy is sort of
let me do my list the economy is soaring
the stock market has ridden by 27% and
unemployment has fallen to an all-time
50-year low under him he think you know
whereas Barack Obama was very much about
global dominance Trump doesn't care
about that he is it's America first it's
America first for the American people
and and you can't knock that
we must abused can I just point out as
former FT reporter when I used to have
caught him but you know a lot of those
things are lagging indicators and he's
inheriting the economy from from his
predecessor and so it's easy if it's an
easy win for him to say to cut taxes and
to sleep great well it's me Texas and
it's not as easy to corporate tax like
he actually did which was a an
incredible feat from something like 37
percent to 21 or 2% that's an incredible
Carol in November the the budget deficit
in the US was the highest level since
the financial crisis and there are lots
of concerns about the way spending as is
outstripping sorry guys what what's that
noise
right overnight in his brief I haven't
got long he's scared to at a moment and
upstairs the admin list have messed it
all up so I need to know who's on the
noise and who's on the nice list okay
okay right
you're good aren't you I mean it's
definitely on the nice listen kid oh
well you are absolute angel you're the
nicest okay
and Greg yes you two have been bickering
so you're on a yellow card as you love
Santa
now listen to me yes I have 47 votes of
no confidence in your ability to be nice
so you have made I've got make it 48 so
now you have made oh no I'm on the
naughty list
oh sorry so by the way if you wondered
why I've brought Andrew it's because my
reindeers are overworked underpaid and
they don't want to come back
well thanks thanks Santa hello Phil
coming up after the break I'll make my
predictions for
[Music]